-Welcome back, everybody.
We're about to play
a brand new game.
It's time for Wedding, Set, Go.
-♪ Wedding ♪
♪ Wedding, set, go ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I'm going to need some help.
She is one of the biggest
stars in the world,
and her new movie, "Marry Me,"
is in theaters February 11,
Please welcome the one
and only Jennifer Lopez.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Wedding, set, go ♪
-Oh, my goodness.
Come here.
Jennifer Lopez!
-Hi, guys.
Okay.
-I know every time --
-What do you have me
doing today?
-Every time you
come on this show --
-Showing up not dressed
appropriately.
I'm positive.
-You never are, yeah.
But this one, I think
you'll like this one.
In honor
of the movie marry me, okay,
Jennifer and I
are going to face off
in some wedding-themed
challenges.
Ever wins the most challenges,
wins the game.
Sound good?
-What do I win?
-Just pride.
-How hard am I trying right now?
-Come on, I know you.
You're very competitive.
This first challenge, we're
going to be catching a bouquet.
Okay? But it's one flower
at a time.
-Okay.
-Air cannons are going
to launch roses at us.
-Wait.
Do they have, like, thorns?
Wait?
-Yeah, look, don't worry
about the canons.
-Canons?
-Don't worry about thrones.
The stem will get you.
They're coming at you
pretty fast.
The whoever can catch the most
before time runs out wins.
Safety is sexy.
-Are you [bleep] kidding me?
-You can't say that.
[ Rimshot ]
You can't say that on
television.
Here we go.
This is...
[ Laughter ]
You ready for this?
They're coming from all angles.
So just whoever
can grab the most.
-Wait, wait, wait.
-Wedding, set...
-Wait, where is --
-...go!
-Ow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Shrieks ]
-Alright, stop!
-I got it, I got it!
[ Laughter ]
[ Shrieks ]
-Alright, stop!
30 seconds.
There it goes again.
30 seconds, stop, stop,
stop, stop.
Stop!
What the...?
[ Buzzer ]
What in the world just happened?
-I can't see.
-I felt like I was in
a fight right there.
That was -- I got punched.
-Did I punch you?
-No, you didn't punch me.
A rose hit from like all angles.
They were aiming.
-I'm sorry if I punched you.
-I got -- I got two.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, so I think you won
the first challenge.
Congratulations
[ Cheers and applause ]
You did -- you did
knock me out of the way.
-Because you got in my way.
-But then I got scared.
-It felt like you
were going to tackle me.
-Oh, my --
How am I gonna tackle you?
-Alright, come over here.
-Okay.
This is the -- this is the next
game we're going to play.
-What's this?
-Oh, my gosh.
What is this?
-This -- well, this one.
-I don't know what to do
with these.
-Thank you very much.
-Because we were under attack.
-Oh, so sweet.
We were under attack.
But you got my back there.
This one is -- this challenge
is called the threshold carry.
Okay, we both have to carry
a weighted dummy...
-Seriously?
-...through a door frame
and then -- and then toss it
as far as we can onto a bed.
Now, whoever can throw
their dummy the furthest wins.
-Wha--
-Since you're our guest,
you can go first.
You can take -- you can take
the groom off there.
-I have to take the groom?
-Yeah, you take the groom
and carry him
to the threshold.
-Oh, my God. He's creepy.
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go.
-No, no.
-Oh, through this one here.
-I thought you were
dancing with him.
-Wait, so how far close
can I get to the bed?
-You can get a little closer.
It's romantic already.
♪♪
Give it good toss,
however, you got to do it.
Heeyah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Wow, that was a good toss.
-I had the last line.
-That was a good toss.
Can we see that in slo-mo?
[ Laughing ]
I hit the last line.
-Look at this toss.
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean...
-He was a 10-footer.
-That's a 10-footer, isn't it?
-It's a 10-footer.
Alright, here we go.
I got to beat that.
-Yeah.
Alright, get ready, Roots.
I'm probably going
to toss it up to you guys.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
He's such a fool.
-Honeybunch.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Not happy.
-Oh, my gosh.
I think Jennifer
won by a foot, by a tiny...
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I definitely won the first one.
-Yeah, you really did get me
in the first one.
Alright, here we go.
This is the last one.
[ Laughs ]
Get ready.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, we're down to our
final challenge, okay?
--Okay.
-It's just not a wedding
without cake.
-Is it real cake?
-It's real cake.
-Oh, my God.
-Baked somewhere inside
each of these wedding cakes
is a wedding ring.
-Top layer or bottom layer?
-I can't tell you.
We both have
to tear our cake apart
and try to find the ring inside.
Alright, whoever finds the ring
first wins the whole game.
This one's worth
10 -- 10,000 points.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wedding, set...
Don't throw it
at by the way.
I already know you.
Wedding, set, go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-There's no ring in here!
Oh!
This is disgusting!
♪♪
No. Stop it!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Be careful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
There's no ring.
-Ha, ha, ha!
A ring!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I found the ring, I found it!
I found the ring right here.
Yes!
-[Bleep]
-Jennifer Lopez, everybody.
-"Marry Me" --
it's very slippery --
is in theaters every
February 11.
We're talking more with Jennifer
after the break. Stick around.